Hello. Welcome to this
educational session on extracellular matrix.
As you see, we have three speakers here, two excellent and one in the
middle.
We're already late, so without
losing our time, I'd like to call Javier
Bravo-Cordero to have his talk. Thank you.
Thank you, Mario. Okay.
You speak ahead.
Thank you. Thanks so much, Mario, for the introduction, and
maybe while they put the slides. First of all, I would like to thank the organizers
for giving me the opportunity to present here the work of my lab.
I'm sure it will be up in a minute,
but I hope you guys are doing fine.
That's not the one.
There you go. Thank you. So, as I was saying, I'm going to share with you some of
the work that we are doing in the lab, trying to understand how the extracellular
matrix and extracellular matrix-related programs regulate metastatic
dormancy.
As you probably know, metastasis is the primary cause of death of cancer patients,
and it is a very complex process in where cancer cells have to undergo multiple
transitions in order to colonize a distant site.
They have to actively degrade the extracellular matrix in order to invade into the
stroma, intravasate and extravasate from the blood vessels, and eventually
colonize these distant sites in where they're not going to restore
proliferation immediately. They're going to enter in a period of tumor dormancy
that can last for many years before they restore proliferation and start
forming metastatic lesions. So my lab has been focusing on understanding the
biology of these disseminated tumor cells by utilizing different
high-resolution imaging technology in order to understand from a spatiotemporal
point of view, what is the dynamics of the cells during dissemination.
And I would like to share with you some of the aspects that we've been touching
during this cascade. So I would like to start showing you how we actually look at
these disseminated tumor cells in the primary tumor.
This is a process that we can study by doing intravital
microscopy, as you can see in this cartoon, where we can implant the tumors or
have
mouse transgenic models and expose the tumor by doing either a skin flap
surgery and putting directly the mouse under the scope or implanted
windows that allow us to visualize the tumor over
multiple imaging sessions. By combining this with two-photon microscopy,
we're capable of access this tissue and perform imaging with low
photobleaching and low phototoxicity.
That will allow us to really capture the dynamic of the tumor microenvironment in
real time, as you can see in this movie, in where you can see tumor cells
escaping from this primary tumor in blue and blood vessels
around. So by doing this type of imaging, what we learn is that there's
a lot of activity within the primary tumor.
And these disseminated tumor cells are very active.
There are different type of motile behaviors.
You can see in this movie of a breast tumor, MDA231,
and where you can see in the yellow arrow what we call multicellular streams,
and in a white arrow, what we call solitary movement, in where the cells are moving
as a single unit. So all these type of movements
require active remodeling of the extracellular matrix.
You can see this stream that is moving along this collagen fiber in red,
and eventually, the cells are capable of degrading the matrix and made a way
to intravasate into the blood vessels.
What we learn is that these disseminated tumor cells actually carry
some dormancy signature that actually help them to remain
dormant at the distant site. And those factors include, for example, TGF-beta,
that contribute to building this dormancy niche when they reach a
distant site, as we will see later.
But in order to eventually colonize efficiently at this site, cells got
to extravasate from the blood vessels.
And again, this is a process that require extensive extracellular matrix
remodeling. And we've been studying this
in collaboration with Ben Marty, David Matthews, by using
zebrafish models. In this system, we can inject the cells in the duct of
Cuvier, and the cells disseminate through the vasculature, and we can do imaging
at the tail of this fish in order to capture this extravasation step.
So we were very fortunate to collaborate with Eric Betzig, Tian Ming,
and Gokul, and utilize one of his latest development, the MoSEC,
which is a lattice light sheet
combined with adaptive optics in order to acquire with high spatiotemporal
resolution this process of tumor cell extravasation.
So I'm going to share with you some of the movies that came out from those studies,
and I will start with this one in where you can see tumor cells.
In this case, we're using MDA231 cells labeled with F-actin in the
blood vessels in orange. So what you can notice is that there is cells
rolling in the vasculature, but you can also notice that there is a cell that
already established the first contact with the endothelium.
And you can see the cell that is actively exploring this
endothelial area, extending this finger-like protrusion that are going to establish
this first contact with the endothelium.
We can see this here in more detail, in where you can see this cell that is
actively protruding in the area that is in contact with the endothelial cells.
You can see all the actin machinery polarizing to that area.
You can see these finger-like protrusions that the tumor cell is forming.
These are called invadopodia. These are structures that are required to
degrade the basement membrane that are localized in that area of contact in order
to start degrading the extracellular matrix.
Eventually, the cell combine all this protrusive activity into a unique
pseudopod, as you can see in the cell in the middle, and this pseudopod is
helping the cell to make their way through the endothelium, and they
are ready to get at the extravascular space.Eventually, the
cells extravasate, and they can survive in these perivascular niches in where
they're going to trigger all these dormancy pathways that keep them in this
quiescent state. So my lab has been really interested in
understanding what are the mechanisms that keep these cells in this quiescent
state, and what trigger
their awakening and their dormancy.
But what we have to take into account is that when we talk the tumor
dissemination and the time to metastasis, we have to take into consideration
that these cells can disseminate very early during tumor progression through a
process that has been described as and early tumor cell dissemination.
So these cells escape the tumor very early.
They can colonize all the sites, and there's
mechanisms that keep the cells in this dormant state are activated.
Now, the patient undergo primary tumor
recession. They're being treated, but the cells still survive at this distant site
evolving, and eventually they are capable of relapse and form metastatic
lesions, as you see by this purple area.
So the field has been really focused on understanding what is the biology behind
these
disseminated tumor cells, how they can remain dormant, what trigger their
awakening in order to define ways in order to eliminate this.
And what we've been learning from the work on many labs in the field, it is what
we summarize here as these dormancy hallmarks.
The best definition we have for these cells is that they are quiescent.
They are arrested in G0. They activate survival pathways.
They also evade the immune system.
They have an intense epigenetic reprogramming
within the genome. The part that we've been focusing in the
recent years is in the context of the extracellular matrix and how
tumor-derived ECM actually contribute to the formation
of these niches and how this can signal back to dormancy.
And as you know, the extracellular matrix is the extracellular component, is the
cellular components of tissues and tumor.
It's produced by fibroblasts within the tumor microenvironment, but also tumor
cells are very active in producing extracellular matrix.
And all of that make up the composition of this ECM
that take into account
the stiffness of the matrix in the three-dimensional organization.
Now,
as important as the matrix is the receptors that the tumor cells express in order
to interpret that matrix as they move along the metastatic cascade are
also really important in order to interpret these different extracellular matrices.
So the question that we've been asking in these recent years was whether these
disseminated tumor cells that I was showing you at the beginning, that they are
escaping the primary tumor. They can control their
fate at the distant site by regulating the composition of the
extracellular matrix and the three-dimensional architecture.
And indeed, what we found is that these disseminated tumor cells that
become dormant, they're very proactive in secreting extracellular matrix, in
particular extracellular matrix that is enriched in collagen.
That's what we call pro-quiescent ECM niche.
And we focus our studies in one of the collagen that it was
highly produced by this dormant cell, which is collagen III.
So this
increase in collagen deposition give rise to this extracellular
matrix that has a specific 3D architecture, as you can see in this
3D reconstruction of this matrix here coming from these dormant cells.
This enrichment in collagen III give this matrix this
more curly and disorganized architecture that is
characteristic of these cells that are becoming dormant.
Now, the question that we wanted to understand is how this matrix that is produced
signals back to the cells to keep them in this quiescent dormant state.
And the way we did that is by taking tumor cells and putting in different
extracellular matrix context. And for this experiment, we use a
biosensor that actually help us to identify the cells that are in G0.
This is a CDK2 biosensor that localize within the
nucleus when the cells are dormant.
And so in this movie,
right here, what you can see, this is one of our dormancy models in the head and
neck tumor. When we put the cells in collagen III, you can see the sensor is
strongly localized in the nucleus, pointing out to the quiescent state of these
dormant cells, and they surrounded the cell of this collagen III matrix that
encapsulate the cells.
Now, if we take a proliferative cells and we put them first in collagen I, you can
see that the cells are actively migrating.
You can see the sensor shuttling between the nucleus and the cytoplasm, suggesting
that the cells are going through the cell cycle.
But if you put now the cells in collagen III, you can start seeing how the matrix
is pushing the cells in this quiescent state.
We see the sensor localized in the nucleus, and we start seeing the rearrangement
of the matrix. So basically, what this shows us is that the matrix can actually
signal to dormancy in order to keep the cells locked in this dormant
state. And how they do that? So we found that indeed the dormant
cells in collagen III can increase the expression of one of the collagen receptors,
DDR1, and through a STAT1, they can trigger the signaling that keep the cells
in this quiescent dormant state. And if we interfere
with this niche, we can actually break this
quiescent, and the cells restore proliferation and form
metastasis.
Now, this process of production of matrix and remodeling of the extracellular
matrix by dormancy is a process that is very active.
You can see in this movie now, this is, again, dormant cells in our head and neck
modeling, where you can see they express an active marker.
They are actively protruding. They are actually
interacting with the matrix, actively remodeling in order to build this niche.
So they are very active in remodeling the matrix.
So we wanted to go a little bit deeper and try to understand how
actually the formation of these matrices is regulated in this
dormant cell.
And as you know, these collagens that the cells produce are triple
helix. They synthesize the single chains,
are synthesized in the endoplasmic reticulum.
And within the endoplasmic reticulum, there is a series of post-translational
modifications that take place in order to form
collagens that are stable at 37. And those
post-translational modifications include proline hydroxylation, lysine
hydroxylation, that form hydrogen bonds between the different chains to make a
structure that is stable and can be secreted and incorporated within the
extracellular matrix.So this process
is taken care of by a series of enzymes,
P4H and LEPRL, that regulate collagen proline hydroxylation, and as
I mentioned, it contributes to the stability of this collagen at
37 degrees. So we ask the question whether these dormant cells,
beyond producing large amounts of matrix, they are very efficient in controlling
the production of matrix by regulating these processes that control
the proline hydroxylation to make a stable collagen ECM.
And what we found was very interesting.
We look at the expression of these collagen hydroxylases in our
dormancy proliferative models, and what we found is that indeed, some of these
proline hydroxylases are upregulated in these dormant cells, in particular
P4HA2, which is one of the proline hydroxylase of collagens.
So we hypothesize that through upregulation of the activity of this enzyme,
these cells are very efficient in forming this matrix that is
very stable and have a high content of proline
hydroxylation. But is it required for dormancy as part of
this ECM regimen program? We knock it down in our
head and neck cancer model, and as you can see, compared with the control, in the
absence of P4HA2, we see the restoration of growth when we put these cells in the
lung, and the cells start forming metastasis.
And we found also similar results in a breast cancer dormancy model,
the D2OR model. Now, how is now the absence
of P4HA2 impacting the landscape of the extracellular
matrix? We start collaborating with Peggy Angel in South
Carolina and perform a special proteomics in order to
understand the special distribution of collagen in these highly
hydroxylated species within these tumors.
And as you can see in this heat map, what we found is, in the absence of P4HA2,
we indeed have a decrease in the abundance of these proline
hydroxylated collagens, collagen III, collagen I, collagen V, that
are actually now decreased within the tumor
microenvironment. When we look at this especially, what we found is that
compared with the awakened tumor, these
dormant nodules, they have high content of these proline hydroxylated
collagens, but also the special distribution as well as the abundant change
when we awaken these cells through
downregulation of P4HA2.
Now we have this matrix that is somehow abnormal.
They have low levels of proline hydroxylase.
How does that matrix now signal back to the tumor cells in order
to trigger their growth? So we did an experiment where we
desolarize these P4HA2 awakened tumors to
get these ECM scaffolds that we recolonize back with
dormant cells, in this case expressing the CDK2 biosensor, and then
we quantify the extent of how these matrix can actually push the cells
into dormancy and to other states.
And what you can see here is when we take the cells and put it in their own matrix,
they immediately enter into quiescence.
We get this increased localization of the sensor within the nucleus.
When we put the cells now in a matrix that is derived from P4HA2
knockdown cells, we see this restoration of growth, the cells proliferating, and a
decrease in the number of cells that are as you see there, suggesting again, there
is this matrix that can signal back and control the state of the cell.
Now, the question that we've been trying to understand now is, how is the matrix
regulating the state? There is very interesting studies
by Irwin et al. in 2003, and what they found is
that by using a mouse model that lacks collagen VI,
they were able to show that this abnormal matrix that is produced, it
actually can influence the activity of
mitochondria. And what they propose in these studies is that mitochondria can
actually operate as a sensor of the extracellular matrix and
sense the abnormalities that could be happening there.
So taking into account this idea and the fact that these awakened
cells now undergo some metabolomic reprogramming, we
decided to look a little bit in detail at the ultrastructure of this mitochondria
in these P4HA2 awakened cells. And what we found is
that, as you can see in these images, in the absence of P4HA2, we get these changes
in mitochondria architecture. We see this enlarged mitochondria that have an
enrichment in the cristae with more large cristae
inside, that suggests that these mitochondria may be now more active.
And indeed,
we look at mitochondrial respiration, we see this increase in basal and maximal
respiration and also ATP production.
So somehow this matrix that is being modified now in the absence of
P4HA2 is modified, is being sensed by the mitochondria that is becoming
more active. How has that been
regulated? So we've been looking at the expression of enzymes that
regulate the metabolisms without the mitochondrion, and one of the enzymes that we
found that is highly upregulated in this awakened tumor is this
enzyme called LDH4A1 that regulate the catabolism of
PHIC to glutamate and utilize NAD as a cofactor,
generating NADH that can be rerouted through the electron transport
chains to produce ATP. And indeed, when we look at the
ratios of NADH and NAD+, NADH in these
P4HA2 knockdown cells, we see this drop in NAD+,
suggesting that indeed this pathway is active, and we can restore these levels
by knocking down LDH4A1, suggesting that indeed this enzyme
within the mitochondria was essential for the status of
NADH in these cells. But is it
important for the awakening of the cells?
We did an experiment, and as you can see here, when we knock down
P4HA2, we get this restoration of growth.
But if we also knock down LDH4A1 in the same cells, we are not
capable of enriching that awakening, suggesting that this is an essential
pathway that is being triggered in the absence of P4HA2 and driven by this
extracellular matrix. An interesting thing that we found is that when we look at
these cells that now are deficient in this LDH4A1 activity, we are
still seeing an increase in cell death markers in the cells, suggesting
that the activity of this pathway in this situation will represent a
vulnerability of these dormant cells that are restoring the growth and entering
into this awakening phase.So with this, I will just to
finish, and this is the
summary of what I presented today.
We showed that these dormant cells are very efficient and produce this
collagen matrix through the secretion of collagen and
controlled by the activity of these P4HA2 enzymes.
And when
we interfere with the activity of this P4HA2, we generate an
extracellular matrix that is abnormal and is not capable,
it's influencing mitochondrial activity via LDH4,
triggering the awakening of these cells.
This is the most important slide of the talk.
This is the people that did the work, and I'm very pleased to have the
opportunity to work with very talented people in the lab many years.
Part of the work was done by Julie DiMartino and then continued by
Daniela DiMartino in the lab, and also all the funding support that we've been very
fortunate to have during these years to continue all these studies.
And for all of you that are in the audience and are interested in working on tumor
dormancy and exploring these mechanisms of dormancy and awakening, we're actively
recruiting postdocs. So please feel free to reach out to me
at the end of the session or wherever
you want. My email is here for all of you that are interested.
And I would just like to finish with two small announcements.
So for all of you that are working in dormancy in the context of breast cancer, we
just launched in collaboration with the Journal of Breast Cancer, this new
collection that we are editing that is
focusing on dormancy and metastatic progression in breast cancer.
So if you have any studies that you're interested in submitting, please take a look
because maybe this will be a home for your study.
And I would just like to finish inviting all of you to the Metastasis Research
Society meeting that will take place next June
in Utah. As all of you know, this
Metastasis Research Society is a small society focusing and
visualizing the metastatic research that has been done in the field.
So for all of you that either work on metastasis or have an interest in working on
metastasis, please become a member and look it up.
It's a very
collegial meeting, and we'll be happy to welcome all of you.
And if you're interested, I'll be around and many other members of the
society as well as members of the board.
So with this, thanks so much for your attention, and I'm happy to take any
questions.
Hi. Great talk. I was just curious, did you see
how quickly it takes for it to
adjust to the collagen III in the native environment, or is
it quick enough that its exposure and vasculature would cause this
change?
I'm sorry, but I cannot
hear you. I think it's because of the-
Is this any better?
Yeah, I think that's better.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was just curious if you saw how quickly it took for it
to become more dormant based on the collagen III exposure, or if it's quick
enough that the exposure and vasculature could induce the dormancy.
Yes. So related to the time of
entering in dormancy, we have seen that in a 16-hour period
when we start plating cells that by definition are very proliferative and
start forming tumors, that we start seeing
entering in quiescence very rapidly by using this
biosensor. And the second half, I couldn't hear the
vasculature aspect. Sorry, can you-
I could be wrong, but I believe vasculature is high in collagen III, so I was
wondering if when they do intravasation, if they can undergo dormancy
due to that exposure.
It's very possible. We see cells extravasating as a single
cell unit, so it's possible that as they reinforce, many
of these cells that disseminate, they carry this dormancy signature that may be
reinforced as they're undergoing the dissemination cascade.
So it's possible that it's reinforced
during transendothelial migration and extravasation.
But we haven't looked at that thing.
Thank you, Jose. Amazing imaging, and I really enjoy your
talk and your work.
Thank you.
But collagen III is basically produced by
mesenchymal cells or stromal cells.
So your model, you're using
fibroblast-generated collagen III matrices to
study how the cancer adapt to that structure?
Yes. So we
identify collagen III through a proteomic assay where we look at
stroma and tumor-derived in a human and mouse.
So the collagen that is more produced is coming
from
these tumor cells is collagen. Now, obviously, we have collagen from the stroma.
What we found in our proteomics is that in the
mice that actually carry dormant cells, we start seeing changes
in the abundance of collagen III coming from the stroma also.
So we think there is some kind of communication there.
It's not just--
I don't know. The tumor cells are also generating collagen III?
Yep.
And the stromal cells are triggering up the collagen III because collagen
III is a reparative type of collagen in most
tissues, and also form parts of the stromal network.
It's not a fibrillar like collagen I that form long
fibers. This is more of a stromal type of tissue.
So you will determine the type of tissue where the tumor will get more
dormant?
Yes. That's a good question. You may think that
tissues that are highly enriched in collagen or microenvironment that are
enriched in collagen III, they're more
prone to become dormant. And the purpose of these studies, by putting the cells
on collagen III matrices, was to kind of test
that hypothesis.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you for amazing data. I'm intrigued by the connection between
collagen I and the mitochondria. I would like to
know more what the interaction is.
Is that interfering with the oxidative phosphorylation?
Is it with the metabolic pathway you mentioned?
So I'm a little bit unclear how the
interaction really happens.
Yeah, exactly. So we are still working on that.
We're trying to see if there is a receptor at the
membrane that is triggering those changes.
We are still working on that aspect.
But yeah, that's a very interesting question that I think is not still well
understood, but I think it's a nice area of explore.
As a follow-up of the previous question, so since you have
collagen get make by the tumor cells and the stroma
compartment, what if you have a mixture of collagen?
So is there any proportion that can prevail and make that
dominant in some way?
Yeah, that's a very interesting aspect indeed.
In vivo, we don't have collagen III by itself.
It's just part of collagen III and collagen I
contribute to the formation of these fibers.
Now, what is being shown is that the abundance of collagen III that get
incorporated in these
big fibers with collagen I can determine the three-dimensional
architecture. Early work showed that the increased abundance of collagen
III within the collagen fibers gives certain
deformability to the molecule, which may also contribute to the
biophysics of the metrics that we know that it can
impact the dormant state. So
some of our in vitro data with isolated collagens,
but then it's a more complex structure, and I think that the balance between I
and III within these fibers may determine the final output.
Okay. There is no other question. So thank you so much.
Thank you.
Okay, so my presentation is about a multicellular
protein named SPARC, also stonectin or
BM-40.
And one of the major function is
to work critically in collagen regulation
and deposition and so on. So there is a sort of
continuity with this presentation, but is very much static and
not
dynamic. So anyway, so it's important to say that many disease are
associated with either SPARC up or down modulation.
And
for example, in bone marrow and primary and secondary
lymphoid organ, this
SPARC is very important in
the homeostasis of the immune response because this organ
are very continuously subject to remodulation
and because they have to respond to
danger, DAMP, and injury.
And SPARC function mainly through the collagen
and in this case, mainly type I and type IV collagen.
And
they do in supporting scaffolding, barrier, and
break, and we see in a moment. So one first
example is
that SPARC is expressed, for example, in follicular dendritic cells
in the germinal center.
And if you have no SPARC, there is no collagen, and
the dendritic cells cannot branch properly.
Therefore, if you immunize
the mice, in this case, for example, with a
MOG peptide to induce encephalomyelitis, you see that there
is impairment in
germinal center formation and antibody production.
Even the B cell development, as the early phases
of B cell development is dependent
as a stroma-dependent phase that depend heavily on
collagen. So collagen is expressed
in... There is no way to point, but you see in the
middle, in
the
stroma cells, they make origin to
osteoblastic and
endothelial niche.
And you also see in the upper
right
part that the CD10 B cell
precursor stay in close contact,
adjacent to SPARC positive stroma cells.
So to
visualize functionally the importance of SPARC, we
follow B cell development according to ARDS, as shown in this figure,
in
bone marrow chimera, in which we transplant
wild-type bone marrow into SPARC knockout mice.
And you see that differently to the control wild-type bone
marrow, in which you concentrate
on the
mature B cells, so the ability to make mature B cells.
You see that
in the wild-type SPARC knockout, you see the
impairment of mature B cells. And this
is not dependent, of course, on the donor
bone marrow cells,
because if we retransplant, we can recollect the bone marrow from
theFrom the chimera, spar chimera, and
re-transplant into wild-type mice, and you see that we can
restore the number of mature B cells
during maturation.
And so mechanistically it looks like that
in the stroma-dependent phase, there is an upregulation of
CD24
on the B cells
precursors and also of P-selectin on
the
stroma compartment, on the mesenchymal stroma compartment
in the bone marrow. And the P-selectin bind
CD24 inducing apoptosis in these cells, and
it appears that this is a sort of checkpoint in B cell development.
So as we say, the collagen is also barrier then break.
To visualize this
case, we look at
mice, lupus-prone mice that develop
autoimmunity. And you see that in absence of
collagen, that is the blue, the upper one is the collagen I and
the bottom
is the collagen IV. You see that
in presence of collagen, we can
maintain the conformation of the follicles
even in case of
an enlargement of the
lymph node because of the
massive proliferation of the
B220 positive,
CD3 positive, double positive,
autoimmune B cells. But what happen if we
cross these
FAS mutant mice with SPAR knockout mice?
So in this case, we have no collagen or very few
collagen, and you see now that there is no more
conformation, and there is a mixture of cells,
including
autoreactive B cells that take contact with cells that
are normally segregated from them, like the
granulocytes. And in this case, these
granulocytes, we will see in a moment, undergo also
activation and netosis, and they
undergo
transformation and become a CLL disease.
So the fact if we take the spleen of these mice, you can
transplant the spleen and see these
transplantable B-cell lymphoma come out.
So the NETs, are
neutrophil extracellular trap, has been described initially by Brickman
and Zelinski, and
they
are DNA threads that are decorated with
proteins
like elastase, MPO, and protease.
These
neutrophils undergo
this sort of suicide when they have to deal with
large fungi like aspergillus and so on.
So they entrap the bacteria or the fungi, and then
they
neutralize with this protein. So therefore, in absence
of collagen, the activated neutrophils that
undergo netosis release also a lot of
growth factor like BAF and IL-6. So they provide
extra stimulation to the autoimmune B cells
and favor their transformation into a
neoplastic B-cell lymphoma.
And
you see that in the SPAR
knockout,
there is a lot of these
necrotic B-cell. You see this protrusion
of
green
DNA. And to visualize that, we have
to see the
stimulated neutrophils on polylysine to be able to see
that. But if you do that on collagen, you
completely block the ability to see the netosis.
And so this necrotic protein that
occurs in the many steps described here,
these are
blocked by the collagen. And this
is because collagen bind
the LIR-1, that is a receptor that is expressed on
immature
cells in the bone marrow. So C-kit lineage negative
cells. And then they become
downregulated along neutrophils
differentiation and are almost absent
in circulating neutrophils. But they regain
again when the neutrophils become activated.
That is, neutrophils activation is anticipate
netosis.
So it's interesting because this inhibitory
receptor is in all cells of the immune
system and differently from other, let's say, inhibitory
receptor that acts on different cells like
dendritic cells and T cells. And so they
are all inactivated
by contact with the
collagen.So
now if we look at another
tumor that is a
myeloid tumor, so like acute myeloid leukemia,
this can come with different flavors, with
different SPARC expressions. So it has been described, the SPARC
high is associated with the more
aggressive
AML because they have a
complex
mutation and oncogenic push. Whereas there
is other AML that are low in SPARC,
and these are those with the mutation with nuclear фоsmin
that are of a low genetic complexity.
And probably to become tumor, this need
additional stimuli which can come from the
microenvironment. So, and
we are now going to show that this is because there is, this
case is inflammation and also NETosi are
probably supporting the NPM transformation.
So indeed, these
are human cases that are either mutated
or,
the
down part, or not mutated in the NPM1.
And you see that the number of
NET is much higher in the NPM mutated
cases. And it's also interesting to see
in the right part what is the expression
of NPM in the wild type, that is in the nuclei, in the nuclear
membrane. Whereas in the mutated form is
localized in the cytoplasm. And also it can
decorate the DNA threads of
netting
AML cells.
So
we have already shown that NET
have some
important immunogenicity because
actually the immunization of
neutrophil extracellular trap
with,
sorry, with dendritic cells that has loaded with neutrophilic
extracellular trap that carry the neutrophil antigens
are able to induce
vasculitis, you see in the right part.
So also,
if you use neutrophilic extracellular trap
to arm dendritic cells against NPM mutant, we can
block the myeloproliferation in NPM transgenic
mice.
Also to say is that the
absence of SPARC in the
mesenchymal stromal cells
in case of, let's say, bone marrow transplantation in SPARC
knockout mice, we can change the status
of the T cells. That you know that there is a sort of
a tolerogenic niche, the bone marrow, in which, for example, the number
of Treg
exceed those
that are present in a lymph node.
And so in this case, in absence of SPARC, we have
in the repopulating T cells, a higher number of activated T
cells, a lower number of bone marrow T cells.
So other than using knockout mice, we can
induce SPARC down-modulation in the bone marrow mesenchymal
stromal cells by
repeated chronic stimulation that can be
by cancer, inflammation, or autoimmunity.
You see in the picture here that
SPARC in the low ones, SPARC is
expressed
in the CD29 cells that are the mesenchymal stromal cells.
And
above you're seeing in red the collagen I.
And on the right part, the induced downregulation
that in this case has been done by
immunizing with dendritic cells loaded
with the NETs. We have downregulation of
SPARC and of collagen.
So what's happening in the bone marrow if we immunize
to induce vasculitis in these mice, and
as we said, in the bone marrow, we change the T
cell activation. We have a lot of inflammation right now.
Inflammation induce
complement
deposition, and with this, we have
induction of NET also into the bone marrow.
And this is not just in a mouse event that we can
provoke, but because we had the chance to look at
a patient with a autoimmune
patient that has been biopsies because of unexplained cytopenia.
And also in these cases, we found
collagen deposition and
in contact with MPO and
with a confirmation that is compatible with
NET.
And therefore we can just close the
circle and then we add the mice, the
NPM mutant mice, transgenic mutant mice from Pier Paolo
Pandolfi. And these are a
very mild proliferation, myeloproliferation.
So we immunize these mice to induce
an extraInflammatory boost
and the netosis. And then
we look
at the
exacerbation of this myeloproliferation.
So you see clearly an increase in
NPM and also the
morphology of this blast that are now
more
an enlarged blast that are no longer
normal,
not only in the bone marrow, but also in circulation.
And so
how much SPARC downregulation is important in this event,
how we effectively prove.
And this was done by,
again, with a chimera. We transplanted the
mutant
bone marrow cells, NPM mutant
in wild type in SPARC knockout mice.
And you see that if you do this in the SPARC knockout mice, we don't need
any immunization, but just the absence of SPARC allow
this exacerbation of the
myeloproliferation with a typical
myeloid blast as we've seen before.
So indeed, also in vitro, we can
isolate the
early progenitor cells and
add the NET and
see how the proliferation of this precursor
occur. And we have proliferation actually in all stage,
especially we have induced proliferation in the
myeloblast.
And this can be partially blocked by adding
antibody or inhibitors for IL-6 or stem cell
factor and almost completely inhibited in the
last on the bottom with NF-kappa
B inhibitors.
So now looking at some solid
tumors.
We went back to actually our first main paper
on SPARC, the data two or three. At that time,
that we finished to have the knockout mice
on the BALB/c background, pure BALB/c background.
So we transplanted tumor in these mice, and
you can see that in the wild-type
mice, the CD45 cells, so all the
leukocytes, are distributed
in the marginal septa that
define the lobular structure of this tumor.
Whereas if we inject them in the SPARC knockout mice,
they are also dispersed in the parenchyma, and there is
difference in the ability of the tumor to grow also because
those in the SPARC knockout mice have cells
producing interferon gamma and TNF.
And this is basically due to the SPARC, not the SPARC of the
tumor, the SPARC produced by the myeloid cells, because if we transplant
now the knockout
donors into the wild type,
we see again the same results of the knockout.
And
instead, if we transplant the wild type into the knockout,
you
have the wild type configuration, and also the growth of the tumor is
the same.
Using another model, that is the 4T1 model, that is the
metastatic tumor, you can see that if we inject the
4T1 into SPARC knockout,
it is-- Okay, you can read that. You see the
fuzzy staining of SPARC. That is the SPARC produced by the
tumor because, of course, the host is knockout.
Whereas in the wild type, that is on the left, you see the
very much
red spot of SPARC in the infiltrated
myeloid cells.
And of course, this
has to do with the ability to do metastasis because wild-type mice make a
lot of metastasis. The knockout mice, very few.
And this depend on
the donor because if we put the wild type in the knockout, we
can correct the defect that we have, again, a lot of metastasis and vice versa.
So in nature, in human tumor, there
has been identified, for example,
signatures that are based on the extracellular matrix, and this was the
case of breast cancer. And one of these signatures, that is the
ECM3 tumor, has SPARC as a leading gene.
Is a tumor very rich in collagen. And ECM3
signature is characterized about
35% of breast cancer and are the most aggressive
tumor, poor response to therapy, and with poor survival.
The prognostic relevance is confined
to those with high-grade tumor.
So we try to model that, but anyway.
So this tumor are also
very poor in immune cells, so T and
K and
dendritic cells, but are rich in
myeloid cells. And also there is difference
about the distribution of the myeloid cells with the non-ECM3 and
ECM3 tumor. In the non-ECM3, the myeloid
cells stay in the
septa, in the stromal septa, where the ECM3 are very in close
contact with the tumor cells.And you see in
this kind of tumor, the difference with the SPARC is stay in the
stroma in a non-CM3,
is all in the stroma, low in the tumor clone,
whereas the CM3 tumor has very high SPARC in the
cancer cells, in the clone, and very low in the stroma.
So we modulated that in the mouse by transplanting,
by crossing the NeuT mice, that are transgenic mice
that develop breast cancer, with the SPARC knockout mice.
And if we inject this cell line derived
from these mice in
wild-type mice, you only see the
SPARC expressed in the stroma
and not the tumor, because the tumor is negative.
So we transplanted then SPARC in this tumor, and now you see
the distribution of SPARC is very similar to the
CM3. And as that, also this tumor
have a lot
of collagen,
and
also they have
EMT because there is down of epithelium-mesenchymal
transition. And also,
since the collagen has been linked,
there is a reference to this paper to
the ability to induce COX-2.
We
see also upregulation of COX-2 in this
SPARC-transplanted tumor.
You also see that looking at the cytokine
produced by these, a chemokine produced by these
two different tumor, you see in this part, the amount
of G-CSF is almost the same, but the transduced tumor
produce much higher amount of GM-CSF, IL-6,
that recruit
myeloid cells, myeloid-derived suppressor cells, especially
the monocytic
subgroup, and also CXCL12 that
make the recruitment of these cells in the tumor sites.
And of course, that if we treat with the COX inhibitor,
celecoxib, you see
that we have a downregulation of IL-6 and
GM-CSF in this tumor.
So,
lastly, there has been shown that fatty
acid by Gabrilovich and his group can reprogram neutrophil
in cancer.
We have
had the chance to show that
stearoyl desaturase 5 induce oleic
acid production in the melanoma, and
this
results in intracellular retention of SPARC and
cathepsin B. This could be a good way to downregulate
SPARC in the
environment. So now to study this, we needed to have a
SPARC, high-expressing SPARC to be able to see
downregulation of SPARC. So we sorted from the
heterogeneous
41 population bulk culture, we sorted the SPARC
high cells, and we derived Clone 5.
This Clone 5 is a higher number of
metastasis, undergo epithelium-mesenchymal transition,
induce a
lot of myeloid-derived suppressor cells into the lung, and
therefore, we now transduce this high-expressing
SPARC with scD5, with desaturases,
and this
reduce now the ability to form the metastasis,
bottom line on the left,
induce oleic acid formation, and
retention of SPARC into the cells.
And this
results in a reduced myeloid immunosuppression of the metastatic
niche. These are cells isolated from the metastasis.
And you see that all the number of total CD11b is
downregulated, but also of Gr-1 high and Gr-1
low, and also important is the MFI of
the Gr-1 is increased. And you see also
morphologically, meaning that many of these immature
myeloid cells become mature, and the mature one are no longer
suppressive. According to that, SD5 downregulate
arginase 1 and key enzyme of fatty acid oxidation.
So mechanistically, it's known that
in macrophages, that
there is endotoxin tolerance
or low-vert inflammation. So low-vert inflammation is when the
NF-kappa B is very active because of
the
P65 and P50
heterodimers, whereas in excess of
P50, we have P50:P50 homodimers that are
inducing
IL-1, TGF-beta, COX-2,
and block instead
TNF-alpha and
IL-12. So we look at the bone marrow-derived
myeloid suppressor cells from wild-type SPARC
knockout. We stimulate them, and then we look at confocal
microscopy, the amount of P50 and
P65, and we see that in the case,
in the left of P50, we have much less
P50 in the SPARC knockout mice than the wild type.
And there is theWhereas the p65
is almost the same. So the possibility to
do p50 homodimer is very
small versus the heterodimer. So therefore, these
myeloid cells from the SPARC knockout mice are more
inflammatory rather than suppressive.
So this is the recap. And basically what
I would like to point out is that in the case of
in the upper right corner, in case the tumor
produce a lot of SPARC, certain tumor, there is
the ability to produce
chemokine and cytokine that stimulate the bone marrow to
release a lot of myeloid cells. They have to do
with the induced EMT collagen and immune
suppression. This can be blocked by
COX inhibitor and oleic acid. And
whereas in the case of the bone marrow,
the downregulation of SPARC in the mesenchymal stem cells is
detrimental because they
impede, in some way,
B cell lymphopoiesis, we have seen that.
And increase myelopoiesis, myeloid cell suppressors, and NET
formation locally. And also in the spleen,
the SPARC downregulation
impede germinal center formation, so we
call that lack of scaffold. And also in case of
in autoimmune spur,
they favor the transition between
autoimmunity to CLL, and this is lack of barrier and break
because of collagen down.
So this is the acknowledge of all my group, especially of Sabina
Sangaletti, who work from her PhD
and along all the post-doctorate with SPARC.
But also would like to mention some other scientists who are been
extensively involved in SPARC research and has been of
inspiration. So if any of you are interested in SPARC, you
can find
their name, and look what they have done on this
subject. So, thank you.
I can see if anyone has question.
Okay. So
don't
take... We don't want to lose time for the last speaker.
That probably
will have a more
interesting topic.
Okay. Well, I would like to thank the organizers for this
opportunity to present our data today.
And what I'm going to present basically involves a very
unique cytokine immune cell interaction,
specifically the CHIL1 neutrophil
signaling axis in breast cancer progression.
And what you see illustrated in the diagram
or the introductory slide is essentially a
pyromamelon T-induced tumor surrounded by red
neutrophils, which in turn block out infiltrating T
cells. As I will tell you very shortly, this is due
to a process of netosis that we heard of just a
minute ago.
So what is CHIL? Well, CHIL is a STAT3 target.
It's actually expressed particularly in the mammary tumors
that are induced by pyromamelon T.
And it actually acts as a major axis of
immune suppression, hitting a key immune component such
as the macrophage. So it actually polarizes
antitumorigenic macrophages M1 into an M2
protumorigenic state.
In addition, it has indirect effects on CD8 cells.
It suppresses CD8 function
and also has other
interesting effects on angiogenesis, and I'll get into those
in the last slide of my talk.
So we showed, some years ago, that CHIL
is produced by the mammary tumor cells through a STAT3
transcriptional axis, and that it induces
neutrophils to undergo this process of netosis.
As a consequence of that,
these DNA NETs surround the
emerging tumor and actually prevent infiltrating
T cells from actually
exercising an antitumor effect. So they're actually
causing immune exclusion, which is a major component
of immune suppression in spontaneous breast
cancer.
We further showed in this paper that if you actually inhibited
neutrophil netosis, you could actually prevent this T cell
exclusion and actually facilitate
elimination of that nascent tumor.
And in fact, it could collaborate and allow
checkpoint inhibitors to function, more importantly, to convert
essentially an immune-cold tumor into immune-hot tumor,
making it susceptible to checkpoint therapy.So one
of the interesting questions that next came up, how does
Chill
rescue the effects that are observed that
we
facilitate upon Stat3 ablation in the nascent
tumors? And to accomplish this, we actually
overexpressed Chill in this inducible polyoma middle T model.
And what we found is that it indeed could
rescue all the tumorigenic and metastatic
effects observed in a Stat3 knockout, which
abrogates Chill expression in the tumor.
So this suggested that Chill was really the primary Stat3
target that's expressed by the tumor that's
responsible for this
effect on metastasis and primary tumor induction.
Another important observation that was made during this
study is that when we overexpress
Chill in the context of the mammary epithelium, we actually
facilitated metastasis on a large scale in the
wild-type middle T. In fact,
these tumors
basically populate the lung as early as six weeks
post-induction, so it's a very rapid induction of a metastatic
phenotype. And we were curious to further
understand how Chill was facilitating this
metastatic process.
We showed that, as we said it in the earlier paper, that
Chill is really responsible for recruiting neutrophils
to the mammary epithelium. So it's a major
chemoattractant for neutrophils, and it actually
induces netosis directly on that neutrophil population.
And all of those are exaggerated in the Chill overexpresser.
Now, one of the other aspects of breast cancer invasion
is a well-known process that occurs during tumor
genesis, particularly in this inducible middle T model and in
human breast cancer in general. That is that during
progression, you get initially formation of a ductal
carcinoma situ, which essentially is defined by
having tumor cells trapped in the lumen of the
duct. But they're still retained in that lumen by a
myoepithelial barrier that prevents invasion and
subsequent metastatic
colonization of the invasive ductal
carcinoma. Now, many studies have shown this
is really a key step in terms of the invasive potential
of breast cancer, and it's an important area to
quite understand this conversion from DCIS to invasive
breast cancer. One of the other interesting aspects that
coincided with our Chill studies is studies have shown
that this transition from DCIS to invasive breast
cancer is correlated with an increase in infiltrating
neutrophils.
So the next thing we wanted to assess is whether or not
the observed metastatic enhancement and metastatic
defect that we observed with the Chill knockout had anything to
do with the retention of the myoepithelial layer.
For those of you who are not familiar with myoepithelial markers,
CK14 is
essentially one of the hallmarks of the myoepithelial cell that
actually surrounds the adjacent luminal cell.
As you can see in the middle panel, the Chill knockout
tumors actually still retain an intact
myoepithelial layer, as evidenced by the uniform circular
staining of CK14 around that
emerging tumor. And just to remind you, these are the
same Chill-deficient tumors that are incapable of metastatic
progression. By contrast, if we look at the Chill
overexpresser, that myoepithelial layer is completely
gone, and this is at a similar time point of induction,
implying that Chill is really an important
parameter in allowing retention of that myoepithelial cells.
Now, as I mentioned in my introduction, that Chill is a major
neutrophil attractant. The next question we want to address,
are neutrophils important in the retention of this myoepithelial layer?
So we actually did a further analysis
of another transgenic strain, in this case, a C3
tag
model, which models basal breast cancer, and we could
show, like the polyoma middle T tag tumor,
that the C3 tag knockout of Chill resulted in
similar retention of CK14 myoepithelial cells.
So in an independent breast cancer subtype, we could
actually show that Chill is really an important parameter in
losing this myoepithelial layer, which again
correlates with the invasive potential of that tumor.
Now, whether neutrophils were involved in this process, given that
Chill is an important neutrophil chemoattractant, was next
assessed by doing a neutrophil depletion.
And we accomplished this by basically using a
depletion antibody for neutrophils,
namely anti-Ly6G. And we actually did
this in the middle T model. We found that
neutrophil depletion essentially prevented the
myoepithelial dissolution, as you can see from retention of
CK14 and Smoc
anti-Smoc as markers of the myoepithelial
layer. We further confirmed that by using independent
markers of myoepithelial cells, calponin 1 and p63.
And again, we could show that neutrophil depletion actually
prevented this dissolution of the myoepithelial
barrier.So what
processes of neutrophils are important in the loss of the
myepithelial layer? As we talked about earlier,
netosis is one of the processes by which
neutrophils can be induced to actually create
immune suppressive microenvironment.
Another potential explanation for this observation
is that neutrophil could degranulate at the site of the
emerging tumor, and thereby modulate the extracellular
matrix environment within that tumor and actually have a
major effect on myepithelial
retention.
Now, these particular
processes of degranulation can be actually chemically
inhibited by a particular inhibitor called Nex-20, which
prevents neutrophil degranulation.
Again, when we treated the Middle T tumors that emerged into
these mice with Nex-20, we found that they retained the
CK14
myepithelial layer, indicating that degranulation was
really a key event in allowing dissolution of this
myepithelial layer. And we could further validate
that by using other markers of myepithelium, including
calponin 1 and p63. And again,
treatment of Nex-20 actually prevented this
dissolution of the myepithelial barrier.
So this raises a question,
which component of the granules are actually
responsible for this observed
loss of the myepithelium? So one of the important
clues to this came from the fact that neutrophil
elastase is really an important
enzyme secreted by neutrophils that actually is important
in degradation and remodeling of the matrix.
Further to this, a previous study by the Kia Marski lab
had shown that the same model, the polyoma Middle T model, when made it
to the neutrophil elastase knockout, actually blocked
metastatic progression, implying that this
particular component was perhaps one of the major
neutrophil components of degranulation that was
responsible for this process. As it turns out,
there's a specific small molecule
inhibitor, Alvestat, that basically is a
reversible inhibitor of neutrophil elastase.
So we next asked the question whether targeting neutrophil elastase
could have an impact on retention of the myepithelial
layer.
As you might anticipate, firstly, we showed that
Alvestat does successfully inhibit neutrophil elastase upon
treatment in this model by looking at a number of known neutrophil
elastase substrates, namely TSP-1 and
elastin. As anticipated, the Alvestat-treated
mice
basically showed inhibition of cleavage of these
key
neutrophil elastase products. So the
particular Alvestat is acting as an
on-target inhibitor of neutrophil elastase.
So we next asked whether using
Alvestat could we actually prevent this myepithelial dissolution.
Again, using the inducible polyoma Middle T, we showed
that treatment of these inducible Middle T with
Alvestat essentially resulted in dissolution of that
myepithelial layer. So you had retention of CK14,
calponin 1, and p63 in these Alvestat-treated
animals. We further showed that these
Alvestat-treated animals actually showed
a reduction in circulating tumor cells, indicating
that they were essentially preventing
extravasation of those tumor
cells into bloodstream, presumably through retention of that
myepithelial boundary. So the next question to
address is: How is neutrophil elastase
compromising that myepithelial layer?
Now, as I mentioned, neutrophil elastase is an important
modulator of the extracellular matrix through
degradation of key matrix components such as laminin and
collagens. And they are actually supporting basement
matrix components that allow the
myepithelial cell to survive through its integrin receptors.
So you can well imagine that upon degradation of laminin and
collagens, you lose that supporting basement membrane,
and as a consequence of that, integrins become
disengaged, and those myepithelial cells undergo a
process of anoikis or programmed cell death due to lack
adhesion to matrix.
So firstly, we wanted to see whether or not Chill promotes
metastasis through neutrophil-mediated ECM
modeling. And again, if we look at our system
where we overexpress Chill in the Middle T system, we could show
that Chill, through its recruitment of neutrophils, can
massively remodel the laminin and collagen
extracellular matrix, essentially degrading it such that
it essentially is eliminated. And as a
result of that,
you can actually see that
essentially you lose that supporting basement membrane that the
myepithelial cell
requires.We further showed that as a consequence of this,
if you delete or deplete neutrophils in these CHILL
overexpressing mice, you could abrogate that phenomena.
So again, this CHILL-dependent remodeling of the
ECM was dependent on neutrophils.
And again, as I further alluded to, the numbers of circulating
polyamidal T tumor cells were
correspondingly reduced when we actually looked at
this Lys6G depletion of neutrophils.
And again, if you look at the retention of laminin
and collagen IV, you can see that loss of neutrophils in this
overexpression scenario led to retention of those
basement membrane components, indicating that this
really is a CHILL-dependent neutrophil remodeling of the
ECM that's required for retention of the
myepithelial cells and essentially
survival of those. To further address this,
we showed that using an alvestat, we could
prevent this degradation of laminin and collagen,
again implicating the importance of neutrophil elastase
in remodeling these key components of the basement membrane.
Now, as I mentioned previously, that this basement
membrane serves as an important cell survival
aspect for myepithelial cell growth
and retention. And we can see from-- Sorry, I'll go
back. You can see that when we look at the
active apoptotic
cell death within the CK14 population,
when we use alvestat, we essentially block this myepithelial cell
death. And this, again, is correlated with,
again, engagement of integrins on the myepithelial cells with
key integrin pathways such as focal fact,
implying that neutrophils
really essentially destroy this supporting basement
membrane that supports myepithelial retention.
And that, in turn, prevents metastatic spread of
the invasive breast cancer.
So what I've basically shown you today is neutrophils through the
CHILL axis really are important in remodeling
the ECM as a driver of cancer progression and
metastasis. And they do so via a number of different
mechanisms. First, through degranulation and neutrophil elastase,
which turns over the basement membrane and causes the
myepithelial cells to lose essentially important
cell survival signal. This then allows the emerging
tumor cell to contact the
surrounding
stroma and begin its invasion process.
The second mechanism, as I alluded to at the beginning of my talk, is the
capacity of
neutrophils to undergo netosis and essentially form nets around
those tumors, thereby preventing infiltrating T cells
from essentially eliminating those nascent
tumor cells. So CHILL actually activates both those
axes, and both probably are involved in allowing
those tumors to eventually escape and
eventually colonize distal metastatic sites.
So in conclusion,
there really is important data that I presented
here that shows that CHILL is a major driver of metastasis
through T cells exclusion and myepithelial
dissolution, and all of this is occurring through neutrophils.
Another aspect that I haven't had time to talk about in this
presentation is also mediated by CHILL.
And again, it's through causing vascular
permeability. It looks like CHILL actually is very
important in causing vascular permeability and thereby
allowing
essentially an exit point for
metastasizing tumor cells. With that, I'll
conclude and acknowledge the various people in the lab.
This work was done by Tarek Difour and Adalyn Nasay, with
assistance from a number of key people in the lab.
And we had also very important collaborators,
Dr. Jack Elias, who provided us with blocking antibodies to
CHILL.
Dr. Morag Park, who provided us with human samples, which
we validated this phenomenon in human breast cancer.
Dr. Peter Siegel, who provided us with much of the
neutrophil biology that I discussed, and Dr.
Kim Marske, who provided us with the neutrophil elastase
knockout, which allowed us to validate the importance of
neutrophil elastase in retention of the myepithelial layer.
With that, I'll conclude and take questions.
Oh, I start. Could CHILL
also be
useful to prevent vasculitis?
Which?
Autoimmune vasculitis.
Potentially.
CHILL has actually been
associated with a number of inflammatory diseases,
one of them being asthma.
So that's is good candidate for that.
Yeah. In addition,
a lot of neurogenerative disorders like Alzheimer's, believe it or not,
have been implicated in CHILL. As it turns out, astrocytes can
also express CHILL.And that actually causes the
degeneration of
neurons as a consequence of this inflammatory effect.
You have question? I don't know who's the first. Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Go ahead.
I was curious if, one, you knew what was initially inducing CHIL
in these cells, and two, if once the basement membrane's already been
broken, if it's discovered, say, a later stage of cancer, could
this still be used to treat it?
Yes.
The first question is how we got onto this CHIL was kind of alluded to at the
beginning of the talk. We actually knocked out STAT3 in
the mammary epithelium of the polyoma Middle T model and showed what
happened was it did not have an effect on primary growth,
but it resulted in essentially a loss of immune suppression,
which enabled an immune system to come in and eliminate that tumor.
So that led us to the identification of CHIL as the
primary immune suppressive factor that was produced
by STAT3 transcription in the tumor cell.
So that was essentially the gist of the
story. And we showed in that slide where we overexpressed
CHIL in the STAT3-deficient background, we could actually
rescue
all the phenotypes that were associated with loss of STAT3,
indicating it was the primary STAT3 target responsible for
that effect.
Now, the second question was... What was it?
Sorry. Since a lot of this had to do with the basement membrane being intact-
Yes
... if you discover cancer after it's already breached it, could you still
use that drug, the inhibitor, sorry, I forget what it was called?
After it's been degraded. That's a good question.
And we're in fact testing that right now, so we're actually allowing the
tumors to progress to a point where they become invasive and then
hitting them with
Avastat to see if we can prevent subsequent
metastasis. That goes at a subsequent step in
metastasis, which is more of the seeding component.
So as neutrophil elastase is important in actually
allowing colonization of those, that's a real possibility
because those neutrophils could be actually forming nets
around circulating tumor cells. We don't know that yet, but it's
possible that it could play a role in subsequent
colonization into secondary metastatic
sites.
Okay. Thank you.
You're welcome.
In terms of the timing of expression of CHIL in this process,
your modeling sounds as though it implies that this
occurs late in the development of tumors prior to
metastasis. Metastasis can occur early,
but even earlier,
in an earlier session today on tumor evolution, it
appears that the loss of basement membrane accompanies the
evolution of pre-cancerous states in breast and
prostate into invasive cancer states.
So might this mechanism be occurring much earlier during the course
of tumor evolution-
Right
... than metastatic?
So to get at your question, just to put it in context, the polyoma Middle T
model we're using is an inducible model, which involves
doxycycline expression. And in the time
points that I showed, those were two weeks post-induction,
so that's the oncogene is turned on at a very early
stage, and at that stage, you're developing hyperplasias and
adenomas,
early stages of breast cancer progression.
And even at those stages, we can detect CHIL expression.
In fact, it's very interesting when you correlate the levels of
CHIL expression in lesions within the
emerging tumors. Those that have high CHIL
expression tend to
lose the myepithelial layer, even at an early stage of progression.
Those that have low levels of CHIL retain that
myepithelial layer. So CHIL is not uniformly expressed in
all the early lesions. It's expressed in a sporadic
fashion, and it correlates precisely with this loss
of the myepithelial layer.
So it occurs at a very early event, even before the
invasive carcinoma state.
Does it go on
metastasis or?
Yes. That's the other thing. We actually did a
tumor microarray of breast cancer patients of all
subtypes that span the
major four breast cancer subtypes.
All express CHIL to about the same extent.
And then when you look and then further segregate those in terms
of levels of CHIL, we can show that the
cohorts in all subtypes that express high levels of CHIL
have very poor metastatic outcome.
And actually, further, poor response to therapy in addition.
So it predicts both for outcome and
therapy response.
And the question in the middle.
Do you know whether the activity of elastase on the
ECM
occurs differentially
through netosis or classical degranulation?
I didn't quite get that.
I mean,
the elastase is both
present in the nets, in the
thread of the net-
Yeah. Oh, so it's-
... or in the granules that are released into-
Right. Now I got you. Yeah. So we've
done that experiment where we use PAD4 inhibitors and
DNase, and that does in fact partially rescue
the myepithelial. So I thinkBoth aspects of
neutrophils that are both associated with NETs and
those that are actually secreted are both playing roles in
degradation of the ECM.
Okay. Thank you.
And alvestat does not inhibit netosis, so
that suggests that you can eliminate the
netotic component and still have a
major impact on myepithelial retention.
Have you done the double knockout-
Of what?
... polyoma middle T and-
Neutrophil elastase?
Yeah.
No, that was the Kiomarski lab who did that.
No, your genes.
So we got slides from them to look whether or not in
the neutrophil elastase knockout, they retain the myepithelium,
and they did. So that's consistent with the
alvestat being on target to the neutrophil elastase.
But doesn't that hamper the
development of the tumor? The spontaneous development of the tumor is just on the
metastasis effect.
Just on the metastasis side, because you could well imagine those tumors
are all confined. In fact, what you got there is one big
ductal carcinoma in situ that can't invade and is
actually essentially retained in that myepithelial layer.
Okay. By chance, did you look also mast cells?
Mast cells? We haven't looked at mast cells.
Because they also do NET, sort of NET
extrusion.
Yeah. We haven't looked at that aspect.
They have proteases as well, and it's reported they also work
on the basal membrane.
But what we can say with the neutrophil depletion is sufficient to actually derive
retention of the myepithelial layer.
So that seems to be the primary
immune cell type involved in that phenomena that we're observing.
Okay. Excellent. So thank you very much for staying
till the end. And I would like to thank the speakers
and so enjoy the evening.